hey everyone welcome to led live today
we want to ask the question
do your eyes tell you lies
[Music]
find out on this episode of led live
light exposing darkness everyone welcome
to another episode of led live we're so
glad you could join us today
we especially want to thank our patrons
who make this show possible you guys are
awesome you're keeping the lights on and
keeping this program going so we thank
you for that
um today we're going to talk about the
lust of the eyes before we get into that
we just want to let you know
we have all kinds of ways that we like
to engage people
we like to engage people with t-shirts
you probably see some of these on the
show
let's see mikey's got a realized t-shirt
realize realize realize
scotty's got a god so loved the world
michelle's got led live
kindy has a logo yeah
all nice t-shirts you can get those on
teespring check out the description
below for the link and soon
they should be on our own website and
we're excited about that
why do we why do we talk about the
t-shirts well there's a couple of
reasons one
we all like t-shirts i'm not wearing one
today but i like wearing t-shirts
especially to work it's great
two you know teachers help support our
ministry
and three i think one of the the most
foundational underlying reasons for all
this is we know that it's a way to start
a conversation
it's a way to wear your witness people
see that they think twice or they're
like
what does that mean you know you get
people thinking you engage in
conversation with them
and it's a great way to engage with
other people so
we're your witness engage with people
we're all about witnessing and
sharing the love of god with others so
we also have stickers we have a spanish
channel
we have giving assistant or amazon smile
all kinds of different ways you guys can
help support us
and so check those out we hope that they
will be a blessing to you
and to us as well so the last show
this is kind of a series the last show
we talked about was the lust of the
flesh
and uh we kind of brought out this idea
of devotion
versus desire right we talked about the
struggle
in humanity the story of eve in the
garden of eden really kind of typifies
what our whole race is going through do
we choose
devotion to god which is doing things
his way
or do we choose our own desires and
inclination
doing things our way have you guys ever
heard of the law of effect
you have that's right you've heard of
the law of the fact
well edward thorndike was the guy who
came up with the law of effect and
edward thorndike came before
bf skinner he's a precursor to him and
um if you know anything about bf skinner
he was the guy who developed operant
conditioning
you know where an individual makes an
association between a particular
behavior
and a consequence okay well here's what
thorndyke said about the law of effect
the law of effect stated that any
behavior that is followed by pleasant
consequences
is likely to be repeated and any
behavior followed by
unpleasant consequences is likely to be
stopped
right pain versus pleasure we talked
about the idea of hedonism on the last
show you know maximizing pleasure
and minimizing pain and this is
something that
just kind of really makes sense to all
of us right if you do something it's
enjoyable
you want to do it again if it's not
enjoyable you want to stop
but it's also kind of why people develop
addictions right
you know it's we we don't have
the the right amount of self-control in
our sinful state to keep us from being
addicted we'll just keep doing the same
thing over and over again kind of like
those rats that would go to the heroin
water
and keep drinking it until they die and
we're the same way
in humanity when it comes to sin all
right so have you guys heard of the halo
effect
is that a video game no no it's not a
video game
all right good this is fresh i like that
so the halo effect is a well-known
cognitive bias
it occurs when we judge someone or
something
or someplace as being wholly positive
based on a single favorable attribute or
aspect
wow okay so for example physically
attractive people
are perceived to be smarter funnier
and more likeable than less attractive
people
it's actually really messed up sounds
like
like you feel like you can talk to that
person one thing i i
believe and i i've seen in my own eyes
is like
attractive people get more interaction
in public i mean if they're walking
around a store
someone's more likely to smile and say
hi to an attractive person whereas
an uglier person might not even get
looked at
yeah it's kind of sad yeah so did you
know that you'll spend 30 percent more
on branding products
just because they're familiar to you
yeah i
i i experience that every time i go to
the auto parts store
and i'm like do i buy the cheap oil or
do i buy the one that i've seen those
commercials
alright so because i have my notes up
it's going to be a temptation to look at
my notes so the two that are flanking me
do not look at my notes okay because
they'll give away the answers
and i don't want to do that so resist
the urge
okay i'm going to show you guys her some
uh
celebrities and i want to ask some
questions about them okay
so which one of these two do you think
is more educated more educated
jessica jessica alba i would say the one
on the right it seems more like a
teacher looks more like a teacher
okay what about you michelle and kenny i
agree the one on the right
which is probably the left for the
audience no so she actually is
she's uh she's an actress her name is
mayam
vilec and she has a phd in neuroscience
compared to jessica elba who is an
actress
she is also an actress both attractive
people
so based on appearances you wouldn't
necessarily be able to judge
their education level right but one is
actually very educated
at least as far as the world is
concerned what about
these two which one do you think is more
educated more educated
i think the left so who is this this is
yeah and she's uh isn't she ashton
kutcher's wife
right yeah and then the other one is
mila kunis
okay and then the other one cindy
crawford
well i know cindy crawford is more
mature and
well mila kunis speaks two languages
so that makes her really smart
because when you look at their character
they play she play like a real ditzy
girl
yeah you gotta think about all these
things right who's who's the more
educated
cindy crawford and you
cindy crawford wow you guys are split
half and half it actually is cindy
crawford
she studied chemical engineering on a
scholarship at northwestern university
wow so what does she do she's a super
model she's a supermodel
oh she was kind of like this is the
supermodel
okay i just had to like wow
that goes back to familiarity i guess
yeah it does wow
which is interesting because the two
that said cindy crawford were based on
the generation
see familiar we're more familiar i think
she's more mature she's had time to
study i don't think i put this guy in
here
um but but okay i'll just say chemical
engineering is not like
it's not a light subject like i i went
to school with
i i mean my my bs is in chemistry
i know people i worked with people who
had degrees in chemical engineering or
almost
man they are just like next level they
are like brainiac
like you can't have a conversation with
them because you're like what i had an
aunt
they probably loved that she was in her
their classes
i had an aunt that had a degree in
chemical engineering and she used to
work for an aircraft company she
developed some kind of insulation for
aircrafts and um yeah i mean just like
brains these people are so this is not
easy
another another person you would not
expect this you guys have heard of dolph
lundgren right
no no no
are you kidding me rocky iv okay the big
russian dude
oh i know i didn't know his name yeah
that that and he was in like universal
soldier
and like he was he-man and all these
movies right
okay so that guy you would not expect
that he also has a degree in chemical
engineering and he was on his way to mit
with a
scholarship yeah so maybe the you know
acting modeling those are the things
that pay the bills or funds their
passions which are what they went to
school but i mean like if you're going
to be a chemical engineer it's not like
it's not like you're probably going to
be poor either i mean you're probably
going to get picked up by a nice company
and
a lot of them i'm sure make six figures
wow so
i mean these are not um unintelligent
people but by their looks like
dolph lundgren you would not expect that
guy to be like super smart
by looks you also wouldn't expect that
he's a european karate champion
but he is wow um okay
which one of these two do you think is
smarter okay so i don't know the guy on
the right and by smarter we're gonna say
iq so we're looking at james wood and
george clooney
george clooney i know the name the face
wasn't recognizable
wow yeah i'm gonna just go with with the
right
are you going with age again i gotta say
that name yeah i'm gonna say george
clooney
just because james woods is really goofy
so i heard i heard a lot of george
i mean yeah i heard a lot of george
clooney james wood has an iq of 180
it says general iq he's he's actually
this
really smart guy wow he hides it well
yeah
yeah that's terrible there's a general
iq i mean
i mean he could be dumb as a box of
rocks when it comes to tying the shoes
we don't know that but just a general iq
you know problem-solving abilities
however they measure iq
he's actually considered to be really
high
what about these four guys so we have um
we have ashton kutcher we have
uh quentin tarantino we have matt damon
and we have conan o'brien conan o'brien
i would say it's either conan o'brien
wait what are we looking at which one do
you think has the highest iq
who's the most intelligent uh what okay
i would almost say coleman and o'brien
or matt damon one of those two
uh the first one i don't know
that may have influenced your decision
conan o'brien i have no idea
um
it's hard to can you tell by looks no
and i think that's part of the point
right we're supposed to talk about this
yeah
i think the first one what's the first
one ashton kutcher yeah
wait the far right well i know he's a
dressed up
of fun because i know the answer
congress but i mean that is what does
that mean
so yeah yeah you're just gonna have to
pick one and roll with it
i mean if i was just judging by looks
pretending like i didn't know them all
yeah
um conan o'brien he looks like mark
zuckerberg or something right there
sorry
yeah what did you say uh ashton captain
here on the right conan you're tommy
conan and you oh
conan okay yeah that one
i'll go with someone no one picks so the
second from the right
i don't even know matt damon quentin do
you know cool yeah
he looks like a drunk all right before i
answer that question
you guys know who that is oh yeah
richard dawkins
no it's not richard dawes this is steven
hawkins yeah
so all four of those guys have the same
general iq as stephen hawking
wow it's 160. wow
so they're all really smart right by the
world standards
you wouldn't be able to tell necessarily
by looking who was the smartest though
right
so it's quite interesting all right now
we're going to get out of the realm
of celebrities okay okay
and try to see if we can make this more
or whatever
uh more interesting okay
so here are two people and they're both
asian they're both wearing glasses
um one of these i have chosen at random
like i just went to google photos looked
for like
asian dude and threw this guy
into the picture the other one i chose
specifically
for his intelligence which one do you
think
definitely i think on the surface the
guy with the suit you would
imagine imagine that he would be smarter
for my generation people that are much
much much more smarter than everyone
else generally are a t-shirt and jeans
kind of
yeah something with the left yeah or i
could have done that to throw you off
you don't know i'll go with the chinese
guy yeah which one
the chinese guy how do you know which
one's chinese
more chinese yeah
i'll go with the guy on the left so
green shirt or black suit green shirt
black suit yeah my first instinct wants
to say black suit but i'm going with it
it's interesting why do you want to say
black suit for those of you that do want
to say black suit
he just looks like he's a businessman
right so it's appearance-based
yeah right which is kind of the whole
point of this well those that said green
sure you're actually right it is his
name is terence tao
he achieved a score of 760
on the pre-1995 sat he has a phd
at 20 years old from princeton and at 24
he became
the youngest ever full professor at ucla
for mathematics
incredible so yeah he's a math nerd like
big time wow
it's said that he has an iq of like over
200.
super smart guy right what about these
guys
i'm gonna go with the guy on the left
this is all about
don't say left or right just like pick
like colors or something like
the guy with the red and blue shirt or
the guy with the i'm going to get
blue and black jacket guy in the flat
the guy in the jacket looks like a
knowledgeable uncle you know yeah
okay so you're you're getting plaid guy
uh
a guy with a glasses looks alone right
here with glasses
glasses glasses this one's harder but
yeah plaid guy bad guy so you're half
and half
so actually the plaid guy some guy chose
at random
i chose him specifically to look
somewhat like the other guy
but the guy on that's wearing the jacket
with the
the blue denim shirt this is christopher
langan he actually achieved a perfect
score on the s.a.t
he dropped out of montana state
university after concluding his
professors
weren't qualified to teach him anything
abc's 2020 measured his iq between 195
and 210. uh he started talking at six
months old
what he taught himself to read when he
was three who's his mother
and he said he has lived a double life
for years
manual labor during the day and complex
equations in his head at night
he's a construction worker this is like
a beautiful mind dude
right yeah you should be like a mass
architect for like the world's
best buildings or something now the guy
the ones that chose the guy with the
plaid why did you choose him
i don't know he just looks like some
crazy yeah
kind of like yeah you got that einstein
look at something
it's interesting because in both cases
you're choosing on appearance
or features right you're making
judgments on
some single thing high five michelle
i agree the guy does look like an uncle
here's a hodgepodge of guys one of them
i have chosen the others
are just completely at random people
just for whatever reason whatever you
know
i'd go with the pensive guy bottom right
he's like like this okay we're looking
for smarts or whatever
yeah which one of these guys do you
think is the smartest at least by iq now
iq is you know a debatable thing some
people can have really high iqs and some
things and i mean
looks my eyes are gravitating to that
top
left that dude it's like a close-up of
his head with this
looks like a banker yeah okay
i'm gonna go with the 1800s guy in the
white picture i'll go with that too
what did you go with candy bottom right
yeah with the hands in this photo looks
like um
okay so mikey you're going with the guy
that looks like the banker in the top
left
yeah all right ding ding ding we have a
winner oh
nice it's mikey wow this man his name
he's probably the smartest guy you've
never heard of
okay his name is william siddis he has
an iq between 250 and 300.
he was one of the highest intelligence
quotients ever recorded
he entered harvard at the age of 11. he
was fluent in more than
40 languages by the time he graduated
and he worked
his way into adulthood um
embittered over a 1918 arrest under the
sedition act
citizen spent the years from 1921 until
his death at 46 years old
in 1944 running adding machines and
doing
only menial tasks he was like too smart
he was propelled into his his father if
i remember right was a
a famous psychologist he was recognized
to be extremely intelligent at a young
age like he
um you know kind of like christopher
langman he was speaking by like six
months old
he was reading the newspaper by like 11
months old this kind of stuff
he was so smart he was they were
publishing
his tests and results and stuff in the
new york times
he became widely recognized and known
and he um
he kind of went and became a hermit it
drove him to the point where he didn't
want anybody to know who he was
he didn't want anybody to know what he
was doing and he just chose
uh basically this job where he was using
adding machines he could do
payroll basically more efficiently than
computers
you know or calculators you know
whatever they had at the time
and um you know he just kind of
lived his life into oblivion and died
early it's not a diet of loneliness yeah
you think i had somebody with
that kind of brain power and it just
kind of went but that's not the point of
this episode you know it's just
it's kind of a side tangent there's also
something
called the horn effect so we have the
halo effect then we have the horn effect
right the halos and horns it occurs when
we let the overall appraisal of
something be based on
a negative trait okay so it's like the
opposite for example physically
unattractive people are perceived to be
less trustworthy even though there is no
connection between morality and physical
appearance
right that's true now now that's
interesting to me
in in in the wake of like hollywood
always wanted to use beautiful people
or the devil using beautiful people in
your trust yeah because they're earning
your trust yeah
and that was my experience when i used
to dress all goth and everything parents
like i want you to hang out with him and
then they'd meet me and be like oh
you're nothing like i thought you would
be i'm like what do you think i'd be
like
mikey's playing into everybody
all right well we are you know we fall
prey to these physical
attractiveness stereotypes uh we're
deceived by our eyes and minds that's
really the point
they tell us for example that a person
is attracted they must be smarter they
must be funnier all these
other traits compared to less attractive
people and it's through our eyes that we
really gain the appetite for life
we see all the things our heart desires
and we start to
want right and we want more
this is why i believe cigarette ads
involving cartoon characters were
banned in 46 states right right because
kids see that
and they're like oh it's cartoon
character i want to be like that cartoon
character i want to be like joe campbell
who's cool
and they get hooked for life based on an
image i think that's the power of
of this proof actually that advertising
works
we show you an image and it will have a
profound effect on you because
you think of like how large cigarette
companies are if if that was
literally like whatever it doesn't
affect anybody they would take them to
court and be like no way
there's no evidence of this i mean think
about all the evidence that that
cigarette companies have
pushed out into the world that
cigarettes don't harm you you know what
i mean
yet the government was still able to say
you are not allowed to
advertise with a cartoon that's crazy
so i'm gonna show you guys a couple of
videos some social experiments about
this
okay the first one um if you can see the
image
it's it's so ironic to me they're
they're talking about this
and of course the the lady that they
have with anderson cooper
she is you know an attractive lady i
actually had to cover up
her blouse with a red circle because
it's just like completely
hanging open so it's kind of ironic in
the light of what they're talking about
and doing this experiment on physical
attractiveness and
all that and hooking people in here they
are using the news and what do they use
beautiful people right to
tell you the news so check this out
we wanted to see how big a role
appearance plays in normal day-to-day
predicaments like
if you have a flat tire on the side of
the road who would come and help you
take a look at what happened in our
hidden camera experiment
we hired two actresses nicole and joanna
to pose as stranded motorists with a
flat tire using hidden cameras placed
inside this clothing store and park van
we wanted to see just how many people
were willing to help
[Music]
first up was nicole who doesn't have to
wait very long at all
within two minutes help is on the way
excuse me my tire's flat the only way
that you can help me
yeah i don't know let me go find
somewhere to park are you working right
now am i
oh no i'm so sorry that wasn't the only
good samaritan willing to help nicole my
dad usually takes care of this
within 30 minutes four more jump right
in to help her i can
call my mechanic and come to help you
thank you including this man
bad knee and all we just got over knee
surgery oh no so squatting
down for me is almost impossible at the
moment unable to squat down he does all
he can anyway
even offering his cell phone is it okay
to call long distance
yeah nicole never has to wait long
in fact she received help from 11 men in
just 90 minutes
do you guys mind if i just run grab
something to eat real fast by the time
you come back it should be done
now it's joanna's turn five minutes in
one man does offer to help
help there yeah but after that a steady
stream of both men and women
walk right by joanna almost as if she's
not even there
after 23 minutes help finally arrived
for joanna from this guy
in there miss yeah if you don't mind i
have a flat
for the next hour however another stream
of men and women continued to walk past
joanna
she's offered help only by this woman
who says she'll give her a ride
i'll drive you down there you can go and
i'll wait for you oh that would be
really nice of you
and this man who lends her his cell
phone can i offer you my phone
for somebody great thank you so much we
even gave joanna an additional 25
minutes to see if anyone else would help
is there any way you could drive me
there sure but a total of 51
people walked right past her while she
waited by the flat
almost no one walked past nicole thank
you in total
three times the amount of men stopped to
help nicole are you busy at work right
now
no it's okay then stop to help joanna
and nicole's average wait time next to
that flat tire was one-third of joanna
i'll figure it out beauty bias or just
good luck
what's interesting is the the girl who
was
the less attractive in the thing she was
nicer and more grateful and the other
one was like oh you care if i use your
phone i'm going to go eat and all this
stuff and yet they're still doing it the
one who is
nice and the one that you would really
want to help if you knew the person
like if you knew the women you'd want to
help the one that was
a nicer uh personality you can see how
kind of
both sides are playing into it she's
playing into it by saying you know my
dad usually does this for me in other
words
i'm single right and
the other guy especially the one with
the bum knee you know he's trying to
like really build himself up you know
like
i'm gonna hurt myself yeah you know this
is i can't normally but for you
you know i'm gonna do it i guess he's
hoping to get a favor or something
so yeah interesting how uh beauty bias
can work so i'm going to show you
another one and
this one's from buzzfeed so obviously
life's easier for attractive people
they're thought to be healthier more
sociable more trustworthy
but who cares it's stuff like smarts
determination
creativity that's what determines a
success well in the perfect world but we
got your beyonces you got your zakat
friends you guys keith haversberger oh
very talented people but do you really
think they'd still be here if they
weren't crazy hot
okay i'll concede that maybe
attractiveness plays a small role
in that i am actually gonna go test this
out i'll be right back
so we're going to test this out and i'm
going to make myself up in two different
ways
first i went for that i have a terrible
cold and i haven't left my bed in three
days look no makeup
droopy clothing i just was not looking
my best
in look two my makeup my hair my
clothing we're all
on point oh girl i look so good
then i took both looks to the streets to
ask for cash donations for the los
angeles lgbt center a pretty cool
organization that fights for equality to
see if attractiveness could help me get
more donations
i gave myself 40 minutes for each look
hi do you guys have any change to donate
to a los angeles lgbt center
any change for los angeles lgbt center
that'd be great oh my god okay
thank you so much just got ten dollars
in english that what turkey speak
english would you like to donate
anything
i know i can't thank you okay have a
great day
fair change like any like quarters dimes
anything thank you so much
thank you i literally dude
thank you so much
thank you so much thank you oh wow okay
thank you
yeah for sure that works that totally
works thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you as i expected
when i dress the nines i get more dimes
about
six times as many donations say what
why is this i mean in some areas like
acting and modeling
sure looks play a part but getting
charitable donations
come on well there are a few theories on
how attractiveness influences money
earned
one is something called the halo effect
this is a bias where your overall
positive impression of someone
causes you to think that they have other
positive traits for example
if you see someone's attractive you
might think they're also smart
deserving and trustworthy well looks
like attractive people do have a leg up
in life
that doesn't seem very fair no it
doesn't but
being aware of that bias does help
people think more critically about their
actions
that's a very fair point you know what
is attractive not letting a subconscious
bias affect your life
that's pretty hot that's sexy science
for you right there
very attractive science oh we'll give it
a 10 of the science
what 10 10 out of 10 sciences yes
okay so is that where the term
dress for success or dress to impress
comes from
i mean i guess it could it's almost like
okay we've talked about the pink tax
before never on the show we've looked at
it where like
women products have to charge more and
all are like
the same products pink razors versus
blue razors the pink razors cost more
there's nothing different about them
maybe they're making up for the men i
bet five guys in fries isn't making as
much tips as hooters girls right
so you got the extra to pay for but yeah
it's it's this is eye opening it's crazy
yeah james 1 15 says this then when
desire has conceived it gives birth to
sin
and sin when it is full grown brings
forth
death this is a dangerous position we
put ourselves in
is really what the bible is telling us
you know what i want to start to talk
about with you guys is there been all
these
characters for us to desire right and
um desire to be like how do we perceive
them
uh do we perceive them with the same
bias as
the halo effect right as more
trustworthy
that's smarter etc the list goes on and
on because your initial engagement with
him is by appearance
right same for of course this group you
know
not just the princess but the prince not
just the princesses but the princes
now with the halo effect and the horn
effect in mind
i want to um show how appearances
are marketed to you while communicating
a harmful message
okay i want to show you a pattern a
trend if you will
this is not going to be an exhaustive
list but
i think you'll get the point okay we're
going to go through quite a few examples
and a lot of cartoons are really
teaching kids
the same thing they're teaching the same
principles over and over again
i'm going to start a big on disney they
have an ice capades tour called the
follow your heart
ice capades tour okay and this you will
see is going to be a dominant
theme cinderella tool
two okay you're gonna find two
principles
in here um as we read these lyrics it
says
who's to say the rules must stay the
same forevermore
whoever made them had a chance or had to
change the rules that came before
so make your own way show the beauty
within when you follow your heart
there's no heart you can't win so we
have two principles here
follow your heart break the rules okay
we've talked about this on the show
before the heart is deceitful above all
things
and desperately wicked who can know it
okay so the bible tells us of all the
things in this
world the last thing you want to put
your trust in
is your right your own desires
because they will lead you astray so
let's start to look at this trend
move on to here's some lyrics true to
your heart you must be true to your
heart notice the emphasis right it goes
on your heart can tell you
no lies wait a minute
what did we just read your heart will
lie to you
above all things right it says when
you're true to your heart
it's going to lead you straight to me of
course is in the context of love but
you have to be careful where your heart
leads you according to the bible it's
it's almost like that's really satan's
song i mean god
said you can have every tree but this
one did god really say it's like the
exact contradiction like we just read
don't follow your heart it's deceitfully
wicked this says oh your heart can never
lie to you
yep beauty and the beast i can hear you
you can hear me when we listen to our
what our hearts
i understand you you understand me
that's the place where we can start
words of kindness and forgiveness bring
us closer together not apart when we
speak our minds and listen with our
hearts you're seeing the emphasis right
in disney what about aladdin
right she said he says tell me princess
when did you last let your heart
decide over and over again
nemo my heart will lead me there soon
alright finding nemo peter pan when
there's a smile in your heart
there's no better time to start what
about coco
the rest of the world may follow the
rules
but i must follow my heart we're pitting
them
against each other rules get pitted
against heart
pocahontas listen with your heart she
says more than
more than once right listen with your
heart in other words follow that
more than anything else frozen two
here's where we start to get into the
rules right
it's time to see what i can do test
elements and break through no right no
wrong no
rules for me all these lyrics from all
these songs from all these movies are
being pumped into little children's
minds
no right no wrong no rules listen to
your heart that's what you need to let
guide you in life
and it's an anti-biblical message
moana listen to this dialogue this is
fascinating
here's the chief no one goes beyond the
reef
okay the chief is the authority right
the sole authority here's what she says
i know but if there are no fish
in the lagoon and he stops her moana
and she says and there's a whole ocean
right
but what does the chief say we have one
rule well just one one rule of that tree
in the garden there was one thing they
could not do
just one she goes on
an old rule when there were fish
questioning he says a rule that keeps us
safe
right it's put there for your good
despite how you see it and
she says but dad
noticed the relationship father daughter
and then he says instead of endangering
our people so you can run
right back to the water every time i
think you're past this
no one goes beyond the reef
it's amazing the implications that you
see in this little dialogue and you
can see echoes of the garden of eden you
know
one rule that's all i ask one rule just
obey that
one rule don't eat from this tree that's
it
that's all i'm asking imagine if it
hadn't eaten
that would be a really old rule but at
this point i'd be like it would be an
older
one
it spills over into teenagers too
because they're uh
always trying to climb the ladder in
fact disney owns
such a wide variety of companies they
hit every age group
it's not just disney it's abc it's espn
it's uh marvel um
lucasfilm i mean they've got everybody
right here's a teen show descendants 2.
you want to be cool let me show you how
you don't break the rules i can show you
how so if you're not a rule breaker
i'm going to make you one i'll show you
how to do it right
and then there go on repeating this
these lyrics that are
chilling like a villain another song
from that same movie
is um i can show you all the ways to be
w-i-c-k-e-d wicked
right this is what our promoting to our
teenagers
forget rules let's be wicked let's be
like villains
lady in the to champs adventure
now you're not going to see the word
rule
in here you're not going to see the word
heart in here
but just listen to the song a world
without fences
what does that sound like boundaries
which are rules
where i can run free can and be with
real dogs
who bring the real dog out in me no
walls
and no boundaries where i can be free i
mean this sounds like frozen
right a world without walls and fences
that's exactly where i want
to be you sure about that i mean there's
a lot
of these kind of cartoons i mean you
think about um
uh what's the the abominable snowman one
that we just did
small foot yeah same concept you know
what i mean that there's not
there's this world that's confining them
and you're not supposed to go outside of
that world
i mean you see this reoccurring theme
over and over and over again that is a
pattern
yeah wreck-it ralph they did the same
thing the girl wasn't allowed to enter
the race because it's the king's rules
and all the
girls were like the rules are here for a
reason to protect us and you couldn't go
to another game
you know you were confined to that game
for sure one little interesting thing a
friend of mine pointed out
just about the title lady and the
what is a
yeah tramp's usually somebody that you
know is bad doesn't like you call like a
prostitute or a harlot
so think of revelation the lady
and the
the harlot and the woman
here's some more cartoon characters
minions you know what those guys are all
about right
here they are kevin bob and stewart i
make the rules the rules don't apply to
me
i break the rules this is really the
message
that they are sending to children over
and over and over again
sorry go ahead no go ahead if you were
to define the heart
what is it what what is it that they're
telling you to follow when they say
follow your heart
besides you're gonna say something go
for it yeah it's exactly it's it's just
your desire and like like
if i fall in love then that love is the
truth
so whatever i want is the the trumping
truth how many people have you seen end
up in
terrible relationships because they
followed this
uh what is it called like you're just
obsessed with each other as an
obsession how long i wonder how long the
world would last if we went without
rules for even an hour
right yeah everybody wants rules
everybody needs rules this idea of being
free and doing whatever you want if
everybody had that mentality it'd be a
terrible place to live
i like driving on the left side of the
road right well
i don't like my hands
here's what it says in deuteronomy 5 23
and this is just
after giving uh the ten commandments as
recorded in deuteronomy moses gives the
reason for god's laws or
rules okay so you shall walk in all the
ways which the lord your god has
commanded you
that you may live and that it may be
well
with you and that you may prolong your
days in the land which you shall
possess in other words god is doing this
for your own good and benefit
that's why you see the law
is an expression of the law giver it's
an expression of his
heart and character right
so before we move hastily and just throw
out
the rules and the laws
let's remember that the commandments all
these things that god put in place they
show us what god
is really like and they say something
about his honor
his worth his majesty they tell us what
matters to god
right and so if we have a low opinion of
the law
we have a low opinion of the law giver
so we talked about this
these verses uh yesterday in galatians 5
16 it says i say then walk in the spirit
you shall not fulfill
the law of the or the lust of the flesh
we talked about the principle of
exposure right um
when we're exposed to things we become
more and more familiar
uh with those things and we become more
and more comfortable with them
and uh so that's why this is important
in the realm of
entertainment right you can see how all
this is
coming together yeah no go ahead oh this
is to say yeah
the connection you're probably making is
clicking in my head now
the more you're exposed to these sinful
acts the more normal they
become it has influence in your life
that's that's really kind of what we're
getting at and if something has
influence then it affects how you behave
right and so we talked about this this
battle between devotion
and desire right we've talked about
those verses in galatians
about how there's things that god's
asking of us and there's things that
he's
asking us to leave aside and we have to
make that choice between devotion
and desire and so
there's things like cartoons and they're
they're made to be very appealing very
attractive to our eyes colorful in some
way shape or form now they're not always
all beautiful sometimes they'll make
them more appealing in other ways by
making them funny
right but they make up attractive to us
in one way shape or form
also superheroes right so we have
characters that are like superheroes
right and
uh these people aren't necessarily
always
known for their moral upstanding
right in fact they do some of the same
things that we do
as far as morality is concerned they sin
just like
we do they um and if you and if you
notice a lot of the characters are made
to be very
appealing physically attractive i mean
the women if we're to put it
bluntly they're all made to look like
porn stars yeah basically
painted on correct it's like who walks
around in a bathing suit fighting people
like going to war
and bathing suit like that makes no
sense whatsoever and all the dudes have
like
muscles on top of muscles and they're
just you know big chests small waist you
know
muscular you know they got the guns um
that's that's what they're made of like
they're made to be physically attractive
in appearance and people find themselves
you know interested in that and then it
gains a foothold in your life it gains
influence in your life
i think it's one of the ways that um
lucifer was so
um able as well to to manipulate
all of the heavenly host right he took
two-thirds of them in the initial
um war right one-third ended up going
back
but um you know that that idea that he
took a third part of the stars of heaven
i think they followed him because he was
this good-looking attractive
you know um he he looked the part
and sure would know right yeah the smart
one and
beauty and position yeah closest to god
so question is what are all these things
teaching us and i think you're starting
to see
like what comes out of these things
um here's fill in the blank for you what
do we call the individuals who represent
animations cartoon what
comic book what heroes it's the same
word for both
characters characters characters that's
right remember the word character
because we're about to go through
a short little study here and the word
character is going to become very
important to us
okay so
we're going to go back to genesis as our
springboard as genesis 3 6 it says so
when the woman
saw right lust of the eyes
that the tree was good for food that it
was pleasant to the eyes
and the tree was desirable there's a
word desire again to make one
wise she took of its fruit and she ate
she also gave to her husband with her
and he ate
it was her appetite for the fruit that
drove her for
that drove her to sin it was it was
desire right it was what she seen with
her eye
and just like it says in james that
desire
gave birth to sin
she had been told what was right right
but she chose to gratify appetite she
chose to gratify herself
it was both a physical and a mental
desire okay
notice this this is jesus when he's
tempted in the wilderness okay
we're we're kind of using
um first john chapter 2 15-17 is kind of
a
thread throughout this whole series and
uh it's the lust of the flesh the lust
of the eyes and the pride of life and
you can see how jesus
faced every single one of those
characters those categories
okay so here's the first section this is
matthew 4 1-2 it says
then jesus was led up by the spirit into
the wilderness to be tempted
by the devil and when he had fasted for
40 days and for 40 nights afterward
he was hungry so here's the situation
there's food there's temptation
right there is opportunity for
gratification
jesus is covering the same ground as eve
and here he's dealing with appetite
right okay
now continues in verse three now when
the tempter came to him he said
if you are the son of god command that
these stones became bread
right so he's he's tempting jesus to
doubt
um what god had already said to him
this is my beloved son in whom i'm well
pleased before he went to the wilderness
right so jesus response is the response
that eve
really needed jesus response was
what god says is what i will do
because god's word is life
all right so next temptation then the
devil took him
up into the holy city set him on the
pinnacle of the temple and said to him
if you are the son of god
throw yourself down for it is written he
shall give his angels charge over you
and
in their hands they shall bear you up
lest you dash your foot against a stone
so here he's dealing with in these
temptations he's really dealing with
more than physical hunger how do we know
if we look at this temptation
it's the desire for protection and
recognition
right right if jesus did this god would
protect him and it would be obvious to
all who witnessed
who jesus was like that would that would
just not happen to just anybody
right and here's how jesus answered him
jesus said it is written you shall not
tempt
the lord your god
[Music]
all right last temptation again the
devil took him on an exceeding high
mountain
i've always wondered like where did he
take him you know like what mountain did
he take him to everest did he take him
i mean he could have taken him all over
i don't know
but it was an exceeding high mountain
and showed him all the kingdoms of the
world
and their glory and said to him all of
these things
i will give you if you fall down and
worship me there's that false sense of
emptiness again
it is it is false sends an emptiness
right
he's tempted with the appetite of what
we behold
the temptation for more the temptation
for gain
now all the earth really already
belonged to jesus
he created it right he's really the
rightful owner
but satan claimed the earth because the
earth belonged to man
god put man over it and when man sinned
he forfeited his dominion over the earth
so
jesus in becoming a man he was paying
the price to redeem
the land right and the only way it could
be bought back was by blood
so jesus answered to him jesus said to
him away with you satan for it is
written
you shall worship the lord your god and
him only shall you sir
so this is like in brief jesus has three
temptations he's overcoming in the areas
of the lust of the flesh
the lust of the eyes and the pride of
life okay
now every single day you have choices
to make right you have to choose to get
out of bed
you have to choose to come to work
you're choosing to be on the show
you're choosing all kinds of you're
choosing what you're going to eat
choices choices choices everywhere
choices
right the choices that we make
determine who we are right
and when jesus came to this earth he had
choices that he had to make
every choice he made formed his
character
and because jesus made all the right
choices every single one of us
can be saved from sin
now when you're constantly beholding
programming
that is teaching you to make the wrong
choices
it leads you to the formation of a wrong
character
all right see how that works so as human
beings
um built inside of us is this
urge to look to something greater than
ourselves
right right so if you do not need a
savior because the choices you make
don't really matter then guess what you
get
you get these because you're going to
look up to something
right and if you think about it the main
objective is these characters is not to
teach you to have a godly character
or even be moral it's not the main
objective
you might get a moral lesson along the
way i won't doubt that you know we have
people that write us all the time well
what about this and what about this this
is a good thing that happened and i find
myself saying yeah i agree that was a
good thing that happened
that's not their main objective all
right
i think you know like throughout history
you know this is not a
modern problem this is a this is an
issue that's happened i mean there's
there's tales of these large
beings that you know were were fighting
for the people i mean we know that from
the greeks and the romans and the
egyptians even had
stories like this so you know the devil
understands that this is human nature we
have to look
up to something like this and what he's
doing is just
always constantly offering a counterfeit
version
of what's already dis instilled inside
of us i mean i think it's awesome that
we look
up to god like that we want to serve a
greater being a bigger you know person
and he understands the character of god
so he goes well i'm just going to give
him the
i'm going to give them the you know
bleached out sugar version
and and here you go you get a fake false
version
and it's devoid of all the nutrients and
the nutrients is obviously
the character work that you know that
hero needs to be
inspiring us to be better morally and
you know
unselfish and all that that's right so
these characters
their their goal is not to help you make
moral decisions
right that's not what their their
purpose is they're they're always trying
to save you from some outside invasion
or force or something or maybe save your
life
um but they don't save you from what you
really need to be saved from
right and and to be honest like
they especially like let's just kind of
pick on marvel for a second because
you know iron man is obviously somebody
that was a narcissist
or you know rich wealthy he was he was
somebody that you would not
say is a is a type of
anything god right but then towards the
end of the whole series you see that
he actually really wants to save you and
you know that narcissism you can look
past that
and he really just wants to preserve all
of humanity yeah he's got some flaws but
he wants to preserve humanity
but look at what's going to happen in
the very end like of the world right
satan is going to rally around to fight
against god's government
one last time for the preservation of
life does that make him a good moral
person to follow no but he wants to save
life
so you can see how this this parallel
here
is is not the same as as somebody on
god's side
just because they want to preserve life
does not mean that that is a
is a good thing
so we already mentioned that the vast
majority of these characters are made to
look
uh physically attractive they're
designed to appeal the
to the eyes appeal to the flesh and it's
with that that i
want to look at something amazing with
that thought in mind okay
ezekiel 28 12 says this son of man take
up a lamentation
for the king of tyre and say to him thus
says the lord god you are the seal of
perfection full of wisdom and
perfect and beauty this is a old
testament passage
talking really about satan
if you look at how the bible describes
satan when it comes to physical
appearance it teaches us that he was
beautiful
right he was um but even though he was
he was the one that led people to rebel
and break the rules right
now look at jesus the description isaiah
gives him is this
for he shall grow up before him as a
tender plant
and as a root out of dry ground he has
no form or comeliness
and when we see him there is no beauty
that we should desire him so you look at
the contrast between how these two
are described here we have the one who
is not
the most attractive but what is he
teaching us
not to break the rules and not to follow
your heart
but to do the will of god almost simply
to just
prove a point because jesus was very
much desirable
in his day-to-day life like there was no
beauty found in him physically
right no physical beauty but his
character
was beautiful he was the one that little
children wanted to be around
that people loved to hang out with you
know and
and it didn't even matter
as a sinner like if you're a tax
collector you would still hang out with
jesus because you're like wow this guy's
amazing
like the two girls with a flat tire
you'd probably
more be likely to be friends with the
the uglier one
she was the nicer one you might start a
friendship with the beautiful one but
she's probably not that good in
character
she'll break your heart
so we have this desire to be like what
we see
right but we are not looking at the
right picture
and the right picture is what we need
and that right picture is jesus
and by looking at jesus that's how we're
going to be transformed
and that's how we can be led to make the
right choices
and form the right character that's
right yeah
so that's the study for today we have
one more
you guys have any other closing thoughts
as we
end this episode i wanted you to
elaborate a little bit on the
the character part you said remember
that word character
what would like be a closing thought of
how that wrapped into what you're
saying yeah so the connection is here
they are
they are characters what kind of
character
do they have what kind of character when
you look at them when you behold them
when you start to become like them do
you have what kind of character is
shaped
by beholding them versus beholding jesus
i always kind of think about that when
you see little kids with the minion
backpacks on
you know what i mean like they love that
character they love that little
like you know cartoon and the the
the way that all of those little cartoon
characters are are constantly
you know promoting mischievousness and
stuff
you can just think like is that kid
gonna be more mischievous because
of that i don't know so yeah like you're
talking about these
cartoon characters and stuff these
essentially become like your companions
your friends right you're like spending
most of your day with these guys you've
got them on your backpack like you're
talking about
posters on your wall and it's changing
your character
um there's a verse in proverbs you know
what it is about
uh companions of fools yeah proverbs 13
verse 20
it says he that walketh with wise men
shall be wise
but a companion of fools shall be
destroyed wow
how true well thank you everyone for
watching this episode of led live we
hope that you learned something
edifying some reasons for your faith
and we hope that you all join us with
the next episode make sure you leave
some
comments below make sure you subscribe
make sure
that you hit that notification bell so
you can be notified when the next video
comes out and
we just thank you guys for joining us
and have a good day we will see you on
the next episode
take care
[Music]
foreign